[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit hanna
zimmermann und christian sievers guten
abend hinein russland blockt den zugang
zu instagram das ist eine gewaltige
nachricht wenn man weiß dass 51
millionen russinnen und russen in dem
netzwerk aktiv sind mehr als ein drittel
der gesamten bevölkerung
youtube blockt alle medienkanäle die vom
russischen staat finanziert werden ab
sofort auch das ist eine gewaltige
nachricht der krieg hat das netz längst
erreicht er hinterlässt auch dort
bleibende spuren in der welt jenseits
der bildschirme geht das ganz reale
grauen weiter hier ist die
stellvertretende regierungschefin der
ukraine im zdf interview
es geht nicht um mich es geht um die
ukrainische nation die jetzt unter einem
risiko ist der krieg ist ja nicht gegen
den ukrainischen staat sondern gegen die
menschen ja und die zivilbevölkerung
wird sehr schwer angegriffen
durch die russische föderation und
wir verstehen dass es kein krieg ist das
ist terror
das ganze gespräch mit olga stefanie
china nachher im heute-journal update
wie sich die lage heute entwickelt auch
in städten der ukraine die bislang als
relativ ruhig galten zeigen jetzt
andreas stamm saints for tolerieren und
vögel team
sicher haben sie sich gefühlt als der
luft alarm losging im zentrum von den
mikro war der krieg noch fern bis zu
diesem raketeneinschlag im morgengrauen
eine schuhfabrik zerstört mit ihr die
hoffnung der totmacher einen bogen um
die stadt hunderte kilometer von jeder
front entfernt
sehen sie den schwarzen sack das war
unser wachmann was könnte ich noch sagen
sie sehen es selbst
die fabrik zum glück geschlossen die
umliegenden wohnblöcke arg ramponiert
nichts gegen die seelischen wunden
für ihn war es eine explosion direkt vor
der haustür
wir haben die russen nicht gebeten zu
kommen und uns zu retten uns ging es gut
in diesem land
gegenüber räumt alexander in der wohnung
seiner 90 jährigen tante die trümmer weg
sie habe den zweiten weltkrieg noch
miterlebt sei völlig verstört
explosionen feuergefechte tag und nacht
in bous einem vorort von kiew tobt der
krieg sei tag der 72-jährige anatoli
will im niemandsland den wenigen hundert
metern zwischen den frontlinien benzin
aus autos abzapfen
in meinem haus ist es so kalt
entschuldigen sie mich
viktor hält anatoli nicht auf erhält
seit 15 tagen die stellung am letzten
ukrainischen checkpoint vom rentner zum
landes verteidiger
insgesamt ist es okay wir haben wir noch
die kinder und unsere frauen
die botschaft des sechzehnten kriegs
tages kaum ein ort ist mehr sicher
es drohen noch viele begräbnisse wie in
lemberg mütter weinen um ihre toten sind
[Musik]
das letzte geleit für drei soldaten
darunter taras 25
er war mutig sagte mama wer soll sich
denn beschützen wenn nicht ich ich will
meinen sohn nicht in den himmel heben
aber für mich war er der beste
das beste nimmt ihr der krieg immerhin
kann maria öffentlich abschied nehmen
denn lemberg gilt als relativ sicher
noch
der lange tisch ist noch da die
militärchefs allerdings nur noch
virtuell dabei im kreml zu moskau der
verteidigungsminister meldet heute
seinen präsidenten alles läuft nach plan
[Musik]
gleichzeitig gibt es jeden tag neue
anzeichen dass es alles andere als nach
plan läuft für russland 16 tage krieg
und immer wieder auch diese bilder
russische panzer zwischendurch sogar
kampflos aufgegeben
logistikprobleme taktik probleme und
erheblicher widerstand der ukraine der
ehemalige nato-general hans lothar
domröse ist bei uns ja generell guten
amt
es gibt gerüchte dass präsident putin
zwei hohe geheimdienstler jetzt unter
hausarrest gestellt habe wegen deren
falscher lager einschätzungen in der
ukraine sind sie denn auch überrascht
über das was russland bislang erreicht
hat in über zwei wochen in version
ja überrascht im sinne von positiv
entsetzt wenn der verteidigungsminister
seinen präsident meldet alles läuft nach
plan dann kann er nur meinen diesen
langweiligen plan vier ecken vier
divisionen dem angriff kein schwerpunkt
keine vernetzung mit der luftwaffe
keine zielsetzung und deswegen stoffen
sie so ein bisschen vor sich hin nach 14
tagen im befreundeten donez gebiet nur
wenige meter raumgewinn haben das ist ja
kein großer erfolg aber das kann der
plan gewesen sein erst bisschen simpel
worin liegt denn das wenn panzer
offenbar auch kampflos aufgegeben werden
wenn der nachschub nicht klappt wenn man
da eine armee
beobachten muss die zumindest teilweise
in unordnung scheint
eindeutig in moralfragen ich war wir
sehen immer mit ihren berichten ja dem
präsidenten mit seinem grün gefleckte
wie er aus dem buch heraus die
motivation vorantreibt der ukraine und
wir sehen präsident putin an diesem
langen tisch ist sehr benannt hatten mit
video konferenz mit seinen ministern
überhaupt keine nähe zu den kämpfen
drucken über eine angriffsziel das ja
sehr zweifelhaft ist und wenn der
russische radio und da mal nachdenkt
wird er sagen wir er hat es denn
überhaupt angegriffen also wer die
panzer in ruhe lässt oder von den
tänzern absteigt er hat moralische
schwierigkeiten loyalität probleme jetzt
sehen wir ja immer wieder auf diesen
landkarten gebiete die unter russischer
kontrolle sein sollen was bedeutet das
denn konkret werden die tatsächlich dann
auch flächendeckend durch die russische
armee kontrolliert ich glaube ich das
sehen wir an den bildern nehmen sie mal
so eine militärische mathematik logik
kräfte raum und zeit das sind von nord
nach süd über 1200 kilometer in der in
der breite ost nach west über 1600
kilometer der bogen den sie da
beschreiten 1000 kilometer lange front
mit vier divisionen das ist lächerlich
das schaffen sie nie kontrollieren
können sie das nicht sie haben überall
motivierte ukraine die die freiheit und
das land verteidigen wollen an jeder
ecke können sie angegriffen werden das
zermürbt den angreifer wenn sie das
alles mal zusammen nebenher thrombose
kann wladimir putin diesen krieg noch
gewinnen aus ihrer sicht
praktisch technisch ja er hat ja noch
viel in der hinterhand erkan noch mit
der luftwaffe zu bauen wir sehen ja
jetzt auf die weitreichenden cruise
missile möglicherweise oder die joker
erkannt sehr stören das können die
russen geradeaus fahren wollte walter
walzl einschlagen und dann haben wir
tschetschenien oder aleppo aber
ironische einsätze kann offensichtlich
nicht ich will zusammenfassen technisch
kann er gewinnen auf dauer es wird zäh
und viel blut kosten moralisch werden
die ukraine gewinnen
das bedeutet dann aber dass es
weitergeht so wie wir es im moment
erleben und noch zu viel blutvergießen
führen wird oder ist irgendwie
anzunehmen dass wladimir putin durch all
das was über was wir jetzt hier heute
abend gerade gesprochen haben dazu
bewogen wird aufzuhören mit seiner in
version nein aber seine strategische
zielsetzung entnazifizierung und
entwaffnung wie es genannt hat der
gesamten ukraine wird er nicht erreichen
das sehen wir westlich dessen japan ist
ja überhaupt noch kein erz soll
dagewesen nur ein paar schläge also er
wird dass sie nicht erreichen können die
frage ist was ist gute noch für ihn um
es als sie zu verkaufen zu deklarieren
vielleicht würden in dombach hält wenn
die dort russischstämmige bevölkerung
scheint ja auch nicht begeistert zu sein
oder vielleicht eine landbrücke um mario
pohl richtungen donnerstag die gesamte
ukraine kriegt er nicht und wenn er nach
kiew reingeht wird es ein blutbad
heute heißt das es würden jetzt auch
tausende freiwillige aus syrien etwa mit
eingreifen auf russischer seite was
bedeutet das denn
ja in syrien hat man viel häuserkampf
erlebt das heißt auch die tschetschenen
von denen die sprache ist möglicherweise
dass im häuserkampf statt kampf erprobte
männer knallharte womöglich womöglich
braucht er die um in die stadt rein zu
gehen was wir bis jetzt gesehen habe von
den russen die können es einfach nicht
sehen sie angesichts dieser situation
aktuell die gefahr dass wird die mir
putin zu noch fürchterlich ihren waffen
greift wir sehen ja jetzt bereits ist
dauerbombardement von einzelnen städten
zum beispiel
das ist in der tat so wenn sie
verzweifelt sind und überhaupt nicht
vorankommen aber gewinnen müssen weil
sie überzeugt sind sie machen das
wichtige dann ist die gefahr dass sie
das natürlich lösen wollen mit immer
härteren schläge nie mehr blut solle und
immer mehr
zerstörung der infrastruktur
das ist fürchterlich es muss irgendwann
einen punkt geben wo die beiden
präsidenten sehen dass sie jeweils ihre
gesamt ziel nicht erreichen aber was
halbwegs gut ist dass man zum kompromiss
die analyse heute abend des ehemaligen
nato generals hans lothar domröse ganz
herzlichen dank dafür und wir lieber
guten
das gespräch aber aus termingründen vor
etwa einer stunde aufgezeichnet ja und
inmitten dieser ernüchternden lage will
die eu ein weiteres sanktionspaket gegen
russland verhängen sie will auch
unabhängig werden von russischer energie
und zwar bis 2027 einen sofortigen
importstopp für gas und öl aus russland
soll es aber weiterhin nicht geben sagt
der deutsche bundeskanzler
eu-krisentreffen auf schloss versailles
spiegel leuchter viel gold die umgebung
passt nicht zum thema die tagesordnung
kennt kein anderes eine klinik
das gold von versailles und die
prunkvollen säle des sonnenkönigs stehen
in einem merkwürdigen kontrast zu dem
was auf diesem eu-gipfel verhandelt wird
die französische ratspräsidentschaft
beeilt sich mitzuteilen dass der
tagungsort schon lange ausgesucht war
bevor wladimir putin die ukraine in
schutt und asche legte der krieg stellt
europa vor jede menge neuer fragen eine
nacht lang diskutieren die staats und
regierungschefs ob es einen express eu
beitritt für die ukraine geben könne
nicht nur das jüngste eu mitglied
kroatien reibt sich die augen spring
mode und ich habe über 20 jahre an
unserem beitritt gearbeitet ich weiß wie
kompliziert das ist und ich erinnere
mich auch dass der einzige beitritt der
über nacht passierte bei der deutschen
wiedervereinigung war als helmut kohl
sagte ihr nehmt ostdeutschland auf und
ich kümmere mich um die kosten
also kein express beitritt dafür aber
militärhilfe 500 millionen euro für die
lieferung von waffen und ausrüstung
stellt die eu der ukraine in aussicht
dass es doppelt so viel wie bisher und
etwas was europa bislang für undenkbar
hielt und noch eine frage drängt sich
auf wie hält europa es mit öl und
gaslieferungen aus dem gleichen russland
das in der ukraine krieg führt der
deutsche bundeskanzler lehnt einen
sofortigen importstopp ab genauso wie
österreich italien und ungarn
es ist eine bewusste begründete und
nachvollziehbare entscheidung dass wir
jedenfalls von unserer seite aus die
importe die wir heute in dem bereich der
energie haben in europa nicht einstellen
werden scholz und makro haben immer
wieder mit wladimir putin telefoniert
zusammen und auch einzeln gestern werden
die beiden bei ihren bemühungen von
altkanzler schröder überholt der
unabgesprochen in moskau auftaucht die
freundschaft zwischen putin und schröder
verfolgt scholz schon länger seine
reaktion entsprechend schmale dich das
muss und kann ich zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
gar nicht kommentieren wir werden
sicherlich die ergebnisse zur kenntnis
nehmen können und auch einbeziehen
können all das was wir an eigenen und
den anstrengungen unternommen haben ein
altkanzler zu besuch in moskau während
die eu über eine weitere verschärfung
von sanktionen gegen russland nach denkt
auch dass ein merkwürdiger kontrast
dieses besonderen eu gipfels auf dem die
risse in europa langsam sichtbar werden
der öl und gas lobbyist gerhard schröder
ist also in moskau ex kanzler ist er
auch ist das eine vermittlungsmission
ist das image rettung in eigener sache
ist es beides bilder gibt es keine außer
diesem einen hierauf instagram gepostet
von schröders frau offenbar aufgenommen
in einem luxushotel gegenüber des roten
platzes
bringen wir unsere
hauptstadtkorrespondenten container
banerjee mit dazu genannt chakuza was
wissen wir denn über die hintergründe
dieser reise
gemessen daran wie viel aufmerksamkeit
sich jetzt auf diese reise richtet
wissen wir erstaunlich wenig das hat
fast schon bizarre züge auf der einen
seite der eindruck dass mit gerhard
schröder da jemand nach moskau reist der
aufgrund seiner engen freundschaft zu
wladimir putin vielleicht noch die
möglichkeit hat an das gehör bei ihm zu
finden als andere und vielleicht noch
einen zugang zu dem präsidenten zu haben
der ansonsten ziemlich abgeschottet
wirkt momentan und auf der anderen seite
die tatsache dass niemand genau weiß was
gerhard schröder da eigentlich gerade
mal wir haben von der bundesregierung
heute gehört das sie gerhard schröder
nicht beauftragt hat sie sagt auch sie
ist vorher nicht informiert worden über
diese reise auch der kreml sprecher ein
kremlsprecher hat heute gesagt er hat
keinerlei informationen kann nichts zu
dieser zu diesem treffen sagen und wir
haben jetzt auch in eben im vorhin schon
gesehenen interview mit der
stellvertreterin von selen ski gehört
dass auch die ukrainische regierung
nicht den auftrag gegeben hat für dieses
treffen also was auch immer gerhard
schröder damit platin wladimir putin
bespricht oder gesprochen hat es gibt
kein offizielles verhandlungsmandat was
er dort hat und damit ist diese reise im
prinzip momentan noch nicht mehr als die
meistbeachtete privatreise der welt und
der herzlichen dank dafür also wenig
substanzielles aktuell aber eben eine
welt die sich an jedes noch so kleine
fünkchen hoffnung klammert eben weil es
so wenig hoffnung gibt wir bleiben noch
beim thema anna du hast den überblick
den ersten nachrichten die usa die eu
und die g 7 haben weitere sanktionen
gegen russland verkündet geplant sind
unter anderem höhere zölle auf russische
waren dafür soll russland innerhalb des
der welthandelsorganisation der status
als meist begriff günstigste nation
entzogen werden us präsident biden
erklärte dass es außerdem einen
importstopp für russische luxusgüter
geben soll wodka meeresfrüchte oder auch
diamanten wären davon betroffen und auch
gegen russische oligarchen wurden
weitere sanktionen verhängt
durch den krieg in der ukraine sind die
getreidepreise explodiert experten
warnen vor engpässen und drohenden
hungersnöten denn 30 prozent der
weltweiten weizenexporte stammen aus
russland und der ukraine
was also tun darum ging es heute bei
einer sondersitzung der
agrarministerinnen und agrarminister der
g7 beobachtet hat das treffen valerie
haller kavallerie was ist dabei
herausgekommen und wo werden die
engpässe befürchtet die agrarminister
wollen vor allem ausfuhrbeschränkungen
von getreide verhindern
hilfsorganisationen die getreide
beschaffen und verteilen sollen
unterstützt werden ja und in deutschland
sollen bauern mehr flächen für den anbau
nutzen können all das weil man engpässe
befürchtet vor allem in der arabischen
welt und in einigen ländern asiens und
afrikas ägypten tunesien marokko aber
auch bangladesch beispielsweise sind
angewiesen auf weizen aus der ukraine
und russland millionen menschen könnten
hunger erleiden wird vermutet in
deutschland und der eu befürchtet man
keine engpässe aber vermutlich werden
die preise weiter steigen weizen kostet
heute schon 75 prozent mehr als noch vor
einem jahr mais wurde um 39 prozent
teurer auch bauern machen sich sorgen es
gibt erste engpässe bei düngemitteln und
deutliche preissteigerungen auch hier
ist russland einer der größten
lieferanten beispiel kali seit
kriegsbeginn um mehr als zwölf prozent
teurer in den supermärkten dürfte sich
das bemerkbar machen wobei auch höhere
energiepreise und teures futter bei
lebensmitteln zu buche schlagen auch an
der börse steigen heute die preise der
dax fast eineinhalb prozent im plus die
aktienmärkte setzen auf ein ende des
krieges auf die woche gesehen macht das
ein plus von über vier prozent eine
erholung die auf wackligen beinen steht
danke valerie nach frankfurt
bei ihrem besuch in belgrad hat
bundesaußenministerium berbalk eine
härtere haltung von serbiens präsident
mutet gegenüber russland gefordert zum
angestrebten eu-beitritt serbiens gehöre
auch die bereitschaft die gemeinsame
außenpolitik der eu mitzutragen sagte
werburg serien stimmte zwar in der un
vollversammlung für eine verurteilung
der russischen angriffe hat sich bisher
aber nicht an den sanktionen des westens
beteiligt
der un-sicherheitsrat hat sich mit dem
vorwurf russlands befasst die ukraine
würde mit unterstützung der usa
biologische kampfstoffe entwickeln in
einer dringlichkeitssitzung sprach der
russische un-botschafter von beweisen
die dem verteidigungsministerium
vorlegen mehrere westliche staaten
wiesen die anschuldigungen deutlich
zurück und warf moskau vor dem
sicherheitsrat für desinformation und
lügen zu missbrauchen rückendeckung
bekam russland einzig vom botschafter
chinas
wenn sie den menschen in der ukraine und
denen auf der flucht helfen wollen
können sie spenden zum beispiel beim
aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe
stichwort zdf nothilfe ukraine bahn.de
65 104 106 100 104 106 100 alle infos
auch unter spenden punkt zdf.de oder im
zdf text auf seite 8 190
und so viel in dieser sendung zum krieg
gegen die ukraine jetzt so ein ganz
anderes thema heute abend wenn presse
stellen in unternehmen und politik für
ihre chefinnen und chefs ein sogenanntes
working entwerfen dann ist das
klassische pr sprech und klassisches pr
handwerk es geht dann darum ein paar
sätze festzulegen mit denen man reagiert
meist auf eine unangenehme situation
wenn eine umweltminister wenn mitten in
der schlimmsten hochwasserkatastrophe in
ihrem bundesland seit menschengedenken
erst mal ich zitiere ein boarding
braucht dass wir rechtzeitig gewarnt
haben dann klingt das sehr nach skandal
das zitat stammt aus jetzt aufgetauchten
chat-nachrichten der jetzigen
bundesfamilienministerin anne spiegel
die sich dazu heute erklären muss vor
einem untersuchungsausschuss des
landtags in mainz susanne geld hat die
befragung von bundesfamilienministerin
eine spiegel durch den
untersuchungsausschuss des mainzer
landtags begann vor gut einer stunde
ich habe mich
bislang aus respekt vor dem
parlamentarischen verfahren und als
respekt vor dem untersuchungsausschuss
nicht in den medien geäußert
ich gebe zu dass das gerade in den
letzten tagen nicht einfach war aber ich
werde jetzt zu allen fragen im
untersuchungsausschuss stellung nehmen
eine spiegel als rheinland-pfälzische
umweltministerin an der ahr
chatprotokolle mit ihrem pressesprecher
zeigen nun dass sie am morgen nach der
flut offenbar vor allem um ihre
eigendarstellung besorgt war wir
brauchen ein wedding dass wir
rechtzeitig gewarnt haben im kabinett
ich traue es rosa gemeint ist
innenminister lewentz zu dass er sagt
die katastrophe hätte verhindert werden
können oder wäre nicht so schlimm wenn
wir als umweltministerium früher gewarnt
hätten nach der katastrophe hat sie den
einzigen gedanken angst zu haben dass
der koalitionspartner sie ausbooten
könnte und sie schlecht rüber kommt wenn
sich das alles bestätigt dann hat sie
ihren job völlig falsch gemacht bei der
flut im juli letzten jahres starben im
aartal 134 menschen hunderte wurden
verletzt tausende verloren ihre häuser
im untersuchungsausschuss sagten heute
mitarbeitende von anne spiegel aus die
chat protokolle seien ein zerrbild die
ministerin sei zudem in der flut nacht
gut informiert gewesen
sie selbst meinte sie habe keinen anlass
gesehen in das katastrophenmanagement
vor ort einzugreifen für das sie selbst
nicht zuständig sei experten sehen das
anders und sollte das umweltministerium
kenntnis davon gehabt haben dass
entsprechende extremwetter ereignisse
bevorstehen
und trotzdem von seiten des des
umweltministeriums keine vorwarnungen
gegeben worden seien dann kann man schon
von einem schweren politischen
versäumnis sprechen noch dauert die
befragung von ministerin spiegel immer
in der landtag an es gibt wohl viel zu
klären
die korona zahlen steigen weiter und
gleichzeitig sollen wie geplant ab dem
20 märz die meisten beschränkungen
fallen
gesundheitsminister lauterbach sprach
heute von einer kritischen situation
wir können nicht zufrieden sein mit
einer situation wo 200 bis 250 menschen
jeden tag sterben und es macht mir große
sorge die lage ist objektiv viel
schlechter als die stimmung es sei
falsch nun alle schutzmaßnahmen über
bord zu werfen sagte er weiter und
verwies auf das neue
infektionsschutzgesetz dass wir hotspots
schärfere maßnahmen vorsieht
der saudiarabische blogger reif badawi
soll nach zehn jahren haft freigelassen
worden sein das hat seine ehefrau elsa
veider dem zdf mitgeteilt
2012 badawi in die arabien festgenommen
worden wegen beleidigung des islams
wurde er zu zehn jahren haft und 1000
peitschenhieben verurteilt
gaddafi hatte in blog-einträgen eine
trennung von staat und religion
vorgeschlagen und sich für
meinungsfreiheit und frauenrechte in
saudi arabien eingesetzt
der deutsche fußball-bund hat bernd
neuendorf zum neuen präsidenten gewählt
erfolgt auf den im mai 2021
zurückgetretenen fritz keller nachdem
der dfb in den vergangenen jahren mit
skandalen razzien und strafverfahren
schlagzeilen gemacht hat will neuendorf
jetzt den fußball wieder in den fokus
rücken
1974 wurde jürgen grabowski mit der
nationalmannschaft fußball weltmeister
nun ist der ehrenspielführer von
eintracht frankfurt in wiesbaden
gestorben er wurde 77 jahre alt sein
größter moment mit dem wm pokal
1974 der mittelfeldmann verdrängt auf
den rechten flügel aber zu wichtig um
nicht zu spielen sein tor gegen schweden
im viertelfinale die legendäre
frankfurter flügelzange mit bernd
hölzenbein war geboren vier jahre zuvor
bei der wm in mexiko noch als bester
einwechselspieler der welt gelobt dass
gefühle nicht und dann jeder spieler
will die nationale will am anfang dabei
seine führungsfigur bei eintracht
frankfurt bekannt für glänzende technik
und dribbelkünste zweimal
dfb-pokalsieger
doch beim größten internationalen
triumph dem gewinn des uefa cups 1980
verletzt auf der bank zuletzt
gesundheitlich angeschlagen bleibt
jürgen grabowski doch anders im
gedächtnis
auf wiedersehen
in guter erinnerung behalten das werden
wir tun versprochen und das war unsere
welt an diesem freitag herzlichen dank
dass sie mit dabei waren hier folgt
gleich das zdf politbarometer mit
matthias fornoff
[Musik]
guten abend willkommen zum
politbarometer ob es der mauerfall am 9
november 1989 war oder die
terror-anschläge vom 11 september 2001
sind jeweils zeitenwenden die die welt
einteilen in ein davor und ein danach
jetzt also der 24 februar
2022 russlands überfall auf die ukraine
ist ein kaum für möglich gehaltener
gefährlicher einschnitt drei viertel der
deutschen machen sich sorgen dass es zu
einem noch größeren krieg kommen könnte
der westen will putin mit sanktionen
stoppen
die wirtschaftlichen strafmaßnahmen
gegen russland die auch bei uns zu
nachteilen führen sind richtig das sagen
47 prozent
38 prozent meinen sie gehen nicht weit
genug nur 11 prozent finden dass sie zu
weit gehen
noch fließen gas und öl aus russland zu
uns und immense summen zurück in putins
kriegskasse
wirtschaftsminister habeck hat
angekündigt dass sich deutschland aus
der klammer von russischen importen
befreien werde aber nur wenn das nicht
zu schweren wirtschaftlichen schäden in
deutschland führt
frieren für die freiheit fordert da
deutlich kompromissloser als
bundespräsident gauck
soll deutschland die gas und erdöl
importe aus russland stoppen auch wenn
das bei uns zu versorgungsproblemen
führt ja sagt die mehrheit von 55
prozent nein finden 39 prozent
mehrheitlich dagegen die anhänger von
fdp hfd und linke
auch die befragten in ostdeutschland
meinen mehrheitlich dass ein importstopp
für gas und öl falsch wäre unabhängig zu
werden von russlands rohstoffen
erfordert jedenfalls schneller
entscheidungen in der energiepolitik
um die versorgung in deutschland zu
sichern würden 57 prozent einen längeren
betrieb von atomkraft begrüßen auch die
verschiebung des kohle ausstiegs fände
eine mehrheit gut die höchste priorität
hat für die allermeisten aber der
beschleunigte ausbau der erneuerbaren
energien
der westen setzt einerseits auf
sanktionen um tut ihn zu schwächen
gleichzeitig sollen waffenlieferungen an
die ukraine helfen die russische
invasion militärisch zu stoppen
die bisherigen lieferungen deutschlands
unter anderem luftabwehrraketen und
panzerfäuste finden zwei drittel richtig
29 prozent nicht die ukrainische
forderungen auch nach schweren waffen
wie panzer oder hubschraubern
befürworten 31 prozent 63 prozent sind
dagegen
die ampel koalition regiert fast 100
tage jetzt in der krise nimmt die
zufriedenheit mit ihrer arbeit zu drei
viertel bescheinigen regierungen und
kanzler gute arbeit zu leisten wenn an
diesem sonntag bundestagswahl wäre
könnte die spd weiter zulegen 27 prozent
plus 1
cdu/csu 24 unverändert grüne auch erneut
verbessert 18 fdp weiterhin 9 hf dc1
runter und die linke 5 prozent auch - 1
wir kommen zu unserer top ten also der
bewertung der zehn wichtigsten
politikerinnen und politiker nach
sympathie und leistung auf der skala von
+5 bis -5
ist sahra wagenknecht schlusslicht mit
sehr großen verlusten minus 1,0
vorletzter markus söder verbessert 0,3
friedrich merz deutlich besser 0,4 cem
özdemir schlechter 1 0 davor christian
lindner deutlich verbessert 1,1 auf der
5 winfried kretschmann etwas besser 1,3
annalena baerbock drei plätze nach vorn
sehr stark verbessert 1,4
auf dem dritten platz karl lauterbach
ein leichtes plus 1,42
robert habeck deutlich verbessert 1,6
und ganz vorn olaf scholz auch er klar
besser 1,9
im februar konnten die befragten neu
bestimmen wer in die top ten gehört
nicht mehr berücksichtigt wird angela
merkel weil sie ihre aktive politische
laufbahn beendet hat zum schluss ein
blick auf corona auch wenn der
furchtbare krieg die pandemie scheinbar
in den hintergrund rückt die
infektionszahlen sind zuletzt wieder
stark gestiegen trotzdem sollen ab dem
20 märz fast alle schutzmaßnahmen fallen
dank impfung und milderer omikron
verläufe
den wegfall so gut wie aller maßnahmen
sehen die deutschen mit gemischten
gefühlen 50 prozent sagen ja richtig so
47 prozent finden es nicht richtig die
größte zustimmung findet sich bei den
anhängern von fdp und fw dem
zwei jahre pandemie und jetzt noch ein
krieg mitten in europa wohl kaum jemand
hat das für möglich gehalten hoffen wir
dass das virus seinen schrecken verliert
und der krieg schnell endet das war
unser bericht über die stimmung im land
die grafiken und alle informationen zu
unseren umfragen finden sie wie immer im
zdf text ab seite 165 in unserer zdf
heute app und oft zdf heute.de wie die
repräsentativen umfragen der
forschungsgruppe wahlen zustande kommen
informationen zur methodik und zu den
qualitätsstandards finden sie unter
politbarometer
zdf.de
vielen dank für ihr interesse das
nächste reguläre politbarometer gibt es
dann am 8 april am kommenden freitag
gibt es ein politbarometer extra zur
landtagswahl im saarland nach dem wetter
geht's hier weiter mit der heute show
auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
sogenannte und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter diese karte hier zeigt den
durchschnitt von drei monaten also
dezember januar und februar das ist ja
der meteorologische winter auf der
nordhalbkugel und hier sehen wir der
meteorologische winter war über grönland
viel zu warm genauso richtung sibirien
und arktis und vor allem über europa und
das schauen wir uns genau ansehen hier
fast überall orange und rottöne eine
deutliche temperaturabweichung und salz
2014 waren die winter deutlich zu warm
in europa wir schauen auf das deutsche
wetter heute und zwar kam von südwesten
her schleierwolken reingezogen ist
ändert sich etwas ja und im der nacht
dann vor allem im westen viele wolken
etwas regen sonst weiterhin auf geklagt
mit einem kräftigen südostwind und das
bei frostigen temperaturen von minus
vier bis minus 6 grad minus acht grad
nach südosten und plus acht grad ganz im
westen deutschlands morgen im osten
weiterhin viel sonnenschein genauso wie
ganz im norden und richtung bayern sonst
aber viele wolken nach westen hin mit
temperaturen von sieben grad an der
ostsee und 16 grad am niederrhein oder
aber auch am oberrhein die nächsten tage
gibt es durchaus mal immer wieder regen
am sonntag im südwesten sonst aber viel
sonnenschein bei neun bis 17 grad und
das nächste mal deutlich mehr regen
erwarten wir dann am dienstag und das
sogar bei temperaturen bis 18 grad ein
schöner abend